this session on uh house bill 1279
prior to calling representative roy to
the hearings i'd like to start with the
representative
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
thank you
with that i will
open the hearing 1279
representative roy you're welcome to
begin your testimony
thank you good morning madam chairman
chairman and committee members
this is going to be real short this bill
is attached
um intrinsically to the bill i spoke to
you about uh about week and a half two
weeks ago regarding the alimony
and um the status of the parties
afterwards
i am still unfortunately for the last
week i was a little under the weather so
i wasn't able to get yeah i know the uh
the bill finished the
amendment finished i wanted to
i'm going to continue working with the
judicial
representative
to
see if we can get something that's
acceptable to the judicial branch and
get it back to you before you uh need to
have it for exec
again this all this does is strike out
the portion that says that alimony will
terminate upon a certain thing happening
that is only necessary if the previous
bill
passes
and i'll take any questions
representative ukela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
some reason why this bill could not just
be an amendment to the other bill
um you'd have to ask ols i i asked them
and they said this is how it had to be
so okay i think if it could be i'd be
awesome but
thank you representative belangia
thank you and my first part of the
question is to you madam chair the
the previous bill that he was referring
to was this hurt last week or the the
not the
it was uh house bill 1278 i'm not sure
if you were here or not i don't recall
seeing him there okay thank you
representative may i follow please i
think that was the day that you came in
a little bit later okay yeah so yes
follow me
thank you i'm just trying to piece this
together so unfortunately i wasn't here
to to hear the bill but um i'll go back
and and watch that but
basically
and i know you said you're working on
the amendment but
where i'm getting my brain wrapped
around this
is this essentially saying that upon
remarriage
that the
previously paying party who was paying
alimony
um is no longer required to pay alimony
yeah you're gonna make me explain the
whole last pill so i'll go ahead and do
it real quick thank you
the the
1278 what it does is it says this
if
one party um we'll make it uh we'll make
it a female today there was a man last
time so i want to be fair a female
making a lot of money
a stay-at-home dad
he's got a disability
they're in their 50s
she meets somebody else says you know
what i've had enough i want a divorce
she has no means of income other than
alimony that's awarded to her by the
court
he remarries
has a new friend oh she remarries
remember i switched him now um
and uh has a new family well the the
other party
can't remarry
because they do they lose their alimony
so if they meet someone who alimony it's
predicated upon the idea that someone
being remarried automatically would make
them unqualified for alimony because
their standard of living automatically
changes by mere fact that they remarried
so what i'm trying to do with the bill
and this is what came to me from a
constituent
so it's a real world
thing
is that if someone
remarries the court has to at least look
into the fact that whether or not that
new marriage
elevates the standard of living that was
contemplated by the court in the in the
order for alimony
so the court says okay
you guys getting divorced you get this
much alimony that should give you both
enough to live and maintain as close to
a standard of living as you had when you
were married
the other party remarries and she
remember he remarry somebody who doesn't
have any more money and he does that
doesn't necessarily elevate that so that
the alimony should go away so all it
does is
all i'm trying to do is make that
automatic thing that if you remarry you
lose your alimony or if you uh
cohabitate you lose your alimony i want
the court to have to dig a little deeper
to make sure that it actually
affects the the standard of living
before it's an automatic cut off so that
one person
isn't trapped being for lack of a better
term lonely the rest of their life while
the other person is free to move on and
have family and children
and the other person can't because they
would be financially destitute
did i recap that the way i did last time
okay you're welcome
any further questions
representative long
thank you madam chair uh thank you
representative
you mentioned earlier you're going to
speak to the judicial
yeah uh i'm working um i haven't started
yet but we've spoken now i'm going to
draft an amendment
richard ed from the judicial branch and
get his opinion on it to make sure it's
not going to cause any trouble with the
judicial system to make sure minimal
impact i don't want to clog the courts i
don't want to reopen everybody's head
cases
um so we're going to i'm going to work
on it to make sure it's the least impact
as possible on the court system okay and
and when you speak with them if you
could bring up uh the romantic
relationship yeah that uh get a
definition
yeah definitely i'm going to streamline
it to make sure what i want to do is
look at the existing statue
what would cause someone to lose their
alimony
and address it in the new statute
in such a way that it doesn't really
change it it just requires a deeper dive
into what that means for the person's
seeing none thank you representative i
appreciate the committee's time thank
you
can you fill out a pink card please
i don't seem to have any further pink
cards
uh
is there anyone else who wants to
i guess not
with that we will
close the hearing
1279 we're not exacting anything today
nope
and there was nothing listed in the
calendar stating that we would exact
either
so
um as you can tell representative rice
was not able to be here today
so i will confer with her and there will
be something
uh some communication to let you know
representative yokela i see a question
yes um
i
was wondering if we have a list of the
bills that need to be exact still out of
this committee so that um during this
time we could work on amendments and
stuff like that that would uh in between
now and the next meeting
uh
preparation for that
sure you can stop by and see
uh karen
and ask her
uh if there is a list of bills that have
not been exempt and what they are and
should i'm sure be able to provide you
we're just looking at the list so i know
there's 14 bills are listed as being in
committee though i don't know which may
have been exact and just not reported to
the clerk though
thank you okay beautiful thank you
there you go question answered that's
good
in that case have a wonderful week
and for the republicans on the committee
we will caucus prior to
so you will be notified of your caucus i
will not specify when
i will have a discussion with
representative
you